I have to ask Apple just announced a
mixed reality headset called Vision Pro
for thirty five hundred dollars
available in early 2024. what do you
think about this headset
well I saw the materials
um when they launched I I haven't gotten
a chance to play with it yet so so so
kind of take everything with a grain of
salt but a few high-level thoughts I
mean first
um
you know I do think that this is
a certain level of validation for the
category right where you know when we
were the
primary folks out there before saying
hey I think that this you know virtual
reality augmented reality mixed reality
this is going to be a big part of the
next Computing platform
um
I think having Apple come in
and share that vision
um
will make a lot of people who are fans
of their products
um really consider that
um and then
you know of course the the thirty five
hundred dollar price
um
you know on the one hand I get it for
with all the stuff that they're trying
to pack in there on the other hand a lot
of people aren't going to find that to
be affordable
so I think that there's a chance that
that them coming in actually increases
demand
um for the overall space and that Quest
3 is actually the primary beneficiary of
that because a lot of the people who
might say Hey you know this I think I'm
going to give another consideration to
this or you know now I understand maybe
what mixed reality is more and in quest
3 is the best one on the market that I
can that I can afford
um and it's great also right it's I
think that that's um and you know in our
own way I think where there are a lot of
features that we have where we're
leading on
um so I think that that's that that I
think is going to be a very
that could be quite good
um
and then obviously over time the
companies are just focused on
somewhat different things Red Apple has
always
um you know I think focused on building
really kind of high-end things whereas
our Focus has been on it's it's just a
we have a more democratic ethos we want
to build things that are accessible to a
wider number of people
um you know we've sold tens of millions
of quest devices
um
my understanding just based on rumors I
don't have any special knowledge on this
is that apple is building about 1
million of their of their device right
so just in terms of like what you kind
of expect in terms of sales numbers
um I I just think that this is
I mean Quest is is going to be the
primary thing that people in in the
market will continue using for the
foreseeable future and then obviously
over the long term it's up to the
companies to see how well we each
executed the different things that we're
doing but we kind of commented from
different places we're very focused on
social interaction communication
um
being more active right so Fitness
there's gaming there are those things
um you know whereas I think a lot of the
use cases that you saw in
um in in Apple's launch material were
more around you know people sitting
um you know people looking at screens
um which are great I think that you will
replace your laptop over time with with
a with a headset but um but I think in
terms of kind of how the different use
cases that the companies are going after
um and they're they're they're a bit
different for for where we are right now
yeah so they're gaming wasn't a big part
of the presentation which is an
interesting
it feels like mixed reality gaming such
a big part of that
it was interesting to see it missing in
the presentation well well I mean look
there are certain design trade-offs in
this where
you know they I think they made this
point about not wanting to have
controllers which on the one hand
there's a certain Elegance about just
being able to navigate the system with
eye gaze and hand tracking and by the
way you'll be able to just navigate
quest with your hands too if that's what
you want
um yeah one of the things I should
mention is that the the capability from
the cameras to uh with computer vision
to detect certain aspects of the hand
allowing you to have a controller it
doesn't have that ring thing yeah like
the head tracking in in quest three and
the and the original tracking is is a
big step up from from the last
generation
um
and one of the demos that we have is
basically an MR experience teaching you
how to play piano where it basically
highlights the notes that you need to
play and it's like just all it's hands
it's no controllers but
I think if you care about gaming
having
um a controller
allows you to have a more tactile feel
and allows you to capture
fine motor movement much more precisely
than
um than what you can do with hands
without something that you're touching
so again I think it's there are certain
questions which are just around what use
cases are you optimizing for
um
I I think if you want to play games then
I think that that I think you want you
want to design the system in a different
way and and we're more focused on on
kind of social experiences entertainment
experiences
um
whereas if if what you want is to make
sure that
the text that you read on a screen is as
crisp as possible then you need to make
the the design and cost trade-offs that
they made that that lead you to making a
3 500 device so I think there is a use
case for that for sure but I just think
that they're they're they've the
companies we've basically made different
design trade-offs to to get to the use
cases that we're trying to serve
there's a lot of other stuff I would
love to talk to you about about the
metaverse especially the Kodak Avatar
which I've gotten to experience a lot of
different variations of recently that
I'm really really excited I'm excited to
talk about that too I'll have to wait a
little bit because uh
uh well I think there's a lot more to
show off in that regard